the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or to view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so yesterday we saw how to define double
integrals and how to start computing
them in terms of x and y-coordinates
okay so we've defined the double
integral over a region in plane of a
function f of XY da you can hear me okay
is the sound working can you hear me at
the back now can we make the sound
louder does this work and people are not
hearing me
at the back is it better if people are
still saying make it louder
is it better okay
great thanks so
okay that's not an excuse to start you
know chatting with your friends okay so
when we have a region in the xy-plane
and we have a function of x and y we are
defining the double integral of f over
this region by taking basically the sum
of values of a function over one here
times the area element and the
definition actually is we split the
region into lots of tiny little pieces
we multiply the value of the function at
that point times the array of little
piece and we sum that everywhere and
we've seen actually how to compute these
things as italic and integrals so first
integrating over dy vent over DX or the
other way around
so
one example that we did in particular
was to compute the double integral of a
porter disk whatever the unit disk so
that was the region where X square plus
y square is less than one and x and y
are positive of one minus X square minus
y squared da and well hopefully I kind
of convinced you that we can do it using
enough dragon substitutions and so on
but it's not very pleasant and the
reason for that is that using x and y
coordinates here doesn't seem very
appropriate so in fact we can use polar
coordinates instead to compute this
double integral so remember that polar
coordinates are about replacing x and y
as coordinates for a point in the plane
by instead R which is the distance from
the origin to the point and theta which
is the angle measured counterclockwise
from the positive x axis okay so in
terms of our and theta you have x equals
R cosine theta y equals R sine theta so
the claim is we are able actually to do
double integrals in polar coordinates we
just have to learn how to so just to
draw a quick picture
when we were integrating in XY
coordinates in rectangular coordinates
we were slicing our region by red lines
but we're either horizontal or vertical
and we use that to set up the I created
integral and we said da became DX dy or
dy DX so now we are going to actually
integrate in terms of the polar
coordinates R and theta so let's say we
will integrate in the other well our
first and then theta that's the order
that makes the most sense usually when
you do polar coordinates so what does
that mean it means that we will first
focus on a slice where we fix the value
of theta and we let our very so that
means we fix a direction with X or a out
from the origin in a certain direction
and will travel along this way and see
which part of it which values of R are
in our region so here it will be
actually pretty easy because our will
just well start at 0 and you'll have to
stop when you actually exit a spot or
disk well what's the equation of the
circle in polar coordinates it's just
equals 1 so we'll start when R which is
1 okay what about theta well the first
way that we might want to consider is
the one that goes along the x axis
that's when theta equals zero and we'll
stop when theta H is PI over 2 because
we don't care about the rest of the disk
we only care about the first quadrant
ok so we'll stop at PI over 2 now
there's a as a cash-flow which has the
DA is not dr d-theta so let me explain
to you why ok so let's say that we are
slicing you know what it means really is
that we are cutting our region into
little p
is that are the elementary you know what
corresponds to a small rectangle in the
XY coordinate system here would be
actually a little piece of circle
between a given radius R and R plus
Delta R and give an between an angle
theta and theta plus Delta Theta so I
need to talk to the bigger picture of it
because it makes really hard to read so
let's say that I fix an angle theta and
a slightly different one where I've
added Delta Theta to it and let's say
that I have a radius R and I add Delta R
to it so then you know I'll have a
little piece of XY plane that's in here
and I have to figure out what is its
area what is Delta a for this guy well
let's see this guy actually if you know
my Delta R under the feet are small
enough it will almost look like a
rectangle it's rotated but it's
basically a rectangle I mean with sides
of course are curvy but if they're short
enough it's almost straight so the area
here should be this length times that
length well what's this length that one
is easy it's Delta R okay what about
that length well it's not Delta Theta
it's something slightly different it's a
piece of a circle of radius R
corresponding to angle Delta Theta so
it's our Delta Theta
so times R Delta Theta okay so that
means now even if we shrink things and
take smaller and smaller regions da is
going to be our dr d-theta okay so
that's the important thing to remember
when you integrate in polar coordinates
you just set up your bounds in terms of
R and theta
but you replace da by Rd Rd theta not
just dr d-theta and then of course we
have some function but for integrating
let's say that I call that thing
f then it's the same f that I put up
here so concretely how do I do it here
well my function f was given as you know
1 minus X square minus y squared and I'd
like to switch back to polar coordinates
I want to put R and theta in there well
I have formulas for x and y in polar
coordinates so I could just replace you
know x squared by R square cosine square
theta Y squared by R square sine square
feet and that works just fine
but maybe you can observe that this is
actually you know this is X square plus
y squared it's just the square of a
distance from the origin so that's just
R squared okay that's a useful thing you
know if you don't strictly need it but
it's much faster if you see this right
away
saves you you know writing down a sine
and cosine
so now we just end up with the integral
from 0 to pi over 2 integral from 0 to 1
of 1 minus r squared r dr d-theta now if
i want to compute this integral so let's
first do the inner integral so if i
integrate our minus r cubed I will get R
squared over 2 minus R square over R to
the 4 over 4 between 0 & 1 then I will
integrate the theta so what is this
equal to well for R equals 1 you get 1
half minus 1/4 that's going to be just
1/4 and when you plug 0 you get 0 so
it's the integral from 0 to PI over 2 of
1/4 D theta and that just integrates to
the quarter of PI over 2 which is PI
over 8 okay so that's a lot easier than
the way we did it yesterday
now while here we were lucky okay
I mean usually you will switch to polar
coordinates either because the region is
easier to set up here it's indeed easier
to set up because C bounds became very
simple we don't have that square root of
1 minus x squared anymore or because the
integrand becomes much simpler here our
function well it's not very complicated
in X Y coordinates but it's even simpler
in our fatal coordinates so here we were
very lucky in general you know this may
be a trade off maybe it will be easier
to set up the bounds but maybe if a
function will become harder because it
will have all these sines and cosines in
it if our function had been just X X is
very easy in X Y coordinates here it
becomes R cosine theta that means you
will have a little bit of trick to doing
the integral not a very big one that you
know you know not very complicated
integral but imagine we could get
potentially much harder
okay so anyway that's double integrals
in polar coordinates and the way that
you set up the bounds in general is
you're in so in 99% of the cases you
will integrate over our first so what
you will do is you will look for a given
theta what are the bounds for R to be in
the region what is the portion of my way
that's in the given region and then you
will put the bounds for theta but
conceptually it's the same as before
just instead of slicing horizontally or
vertically
we slice radially so we'll do more
examples in a bit any questions about
this or the general method yes
ah yes so that's a very good question
okay yes why do I measure the length
inside instead of outside oops which one
do I want this one so here I I say this
side is our Delta Theta I could have
said actually other the theta is the
length here here it's a slightly more
it's R plus Delta R times Delta Theta
but you know if Delta R is very small
compared to our then that's almost the
same thing and this is an approximation
anyway so I took this one because it
gives me the simpler formula if you want
if you take the limit as Delta R tends
to zero then the two things become the
same anyway okay
the length you know whether you put our
or R plus Delta R and here doesn't
matter anymore if you imagine that this
guy is infinitely small then whenever
names become the same okay we'll also
see another another proof of this
formula using changes of variables next
week but I mean hopefully this is at
least slightly convincing okay more
questions No
okay so let's see so we've seen how to
compute double integrals I have to tell
you what we are good for as well so the
definition we saw yesterday and
motivation was in terms of finding
volumes okay but that's not going to be
our main preoccupation because you know
finding volumes is fun but it's not all
there is to life and you know now I mean
you know you're doing single integrals
when you do single integrals it's
usually not to find the area of some
region of a plane it's for something
else usually okay so the way we actually
think of a double integral is really as
summing the values of a function all
over this region so we can use that to
get information about medieval region or
about the average value of a function in
variation and so on so let's think about
various uses of double integrals so the
first one that I will mention is
actually something you thought maybe you
could do with a simple integral with a
single integral but it's useful very
often to do it as a double integral it's
to find the area of a given region okay
so I give you some region in the plane
and you want to know just its area so in
various cases you could set this up as a
simple in as a single integral but often
it could be useful to set it up as a
double integral so how do you express
the area as a double integral well the
area of this region is the sum of the
areas of all the little pieces so it
means you want to sum one da over the
entire region okay so the area of R is
the double integral over R of a function
one
let's so one way to think about it if
you're really still attached to the idea
of double integrals of volume you know
what this measures is the volume below
the graph of a function 1 the graph of a
function of 1 is just a horizontal plane
at height 1 so what should be measuring
would be the volume of a prism or with
base R and height 1 and the volume of
that of course would be base times
height so it would just be the array of
our again but we don't actually even
need to think about it that way really
what we are doing is we are summing da
over the entire region okay a related
think we can do so imagine that actually
this is you know some object some
physical object I mean thought to be a
flat object because we are just dealing
with things in the plane so far but you
know you have a flat metal plate or
something and you would like to know its
its mass while its mass is the sum of
the masses of everything every single
little piece and so you would get that
by integrating the density the density
for a flat object would be the area
sorry the mass per unit area okay so you
can get mass of one flat object with
density
let's use Delta for density which is the
mass per unit area so each little piece
of your object will have a mass which
will be just the density times its array
for each small piece and you will get
the total mass by summing these things
so the mass will be the double integral
of the density times the area element
now if it has constant density you know
if it's always the same material then of
course you could just take the density
out and you will get density times the
total area and if you know that it's
always the same material but if actually
it has varying density maybe because
it's some metallic thing but with
various metals so with varying thickness
or something then you can still get the
mass by integrating the density so when
of course looking at flat objects might
be a little bit strange that's because
we are only doing double integrals so
far in a few weeks we'll be doing triple
integrals and then we will be able to do
solids in space but you know one thing
at a time okay
so
okay another useful application is to
find the average value of some quantity
in a region so what does it mean to take
the average value of some function f in
this region R well you know what's the
average of you know a finite set of data
what if I asked you to compute your
average score on 1802 problem sets you
just take the scores add them up and
divide by the number of problem sets
what if there's infinitely many things
because you know they asked you to find
the average temperature in this home
where you would have to measure the
temperature everywhere and then add all
of these together and divide by the
number of data points but depending on
how careful you are actually just
potentially infinitely many points to
look at so the mathematical way to
define the average over a continuous set
of data is that you actually integrate
the function over the entire set of data
and when you divide by the size of the
sample which is just the area of the
region okay so in fact the average of F
so the notation we will use usually for
that is f with a bar on top okay to tell
us the average F that would be so we
said we'll take the integral of f and
we'll divide by the area of the region
okay you can really think of it as the
sum of the values of F everywhere
divided by the number of points in
everywhere and so that's an average
where everything is actually equally
likely you know that's a uniform average
where all the points in the region all
the little pieces of the region are
equally likely but maybe if you want to
do say an average over some solid with
variable density or if you want to
somehow give more importance to certain
parts and to others
then you could actually do a weighted
average so what's a weighted average
well you know in the case of taking the
average of your problem sets if I tell
you well problems that one is worth
twice as much as the others then you
would count twice that square in the sum
and then you would divide you would
count it as two of course when you
divide so the weighted average is the
sum of the values but each weighted by a
certain coefficient and then you will
divide by the sum of the weight so it's
a bit the same idea as when we you know
replace area by some mass that tells you
how important a given piece is so we'll
actually have a density let's call it
Delta again that would be now well we'll
see what we divide by but what we will
take is the integral times of a function
times the density times the area element
because this would correspond to the
mass element telling us how to weight
the various points of our region and
then we would divide by the total weight
which is the mass of the region so as
defined it up there okay so you know if
a density is uniform then of course the
density gets out and you know you can
simplify and reduce to that if all the
points are equally likely okay so why is
that important well that's important for
various applications but one that you
might have seen in physics we care about
maybe where is the center of mass of a
given object so the center of mass is
basically the point you know you would
call that point to be you know you would
say that point is right in the middle of
the object but of course if the object
has a very strange shape or if somehow
part of it is heavier than the rest then
that takes a very different meaning so
strictly speaking the center of mass of
solid is the point where you would have
to come
it all Verma's if you wanted it to
behave equivalently
from the point of view of mechanics if
you are trying to do translations of
that object you know if you are going to
push that object that would be really
where you know where the equivalent
point mass would lie
the other way to think about it you know
if I have a flat object then the center
of mass is basically the point where I
would need to hold it so that it's
perfectly balanced you know and of
course I can do this because I'm not
well whatever but you get a feeling I
mean the center of mass of this eraser
is somewhere in the middle and so in
principle that's why I would have to put
my finger for weight to stay well and it
doesn't work
okay that's but that's where the center
of mass should be I think it should be
in the middle so well anything and call
this face would call this maybe you know
2a or whatever it's but it's really a
special case of the average value so how
do we find the center of mass of a flat
object with density Delta well so if you
have your object in the X Y plane when
it's center of mass will be at positions
that are actually just the coordinates
of the center of mass will just be the
weighted averages of x and y on the
solid okay so the center of mass will be
at a position that I will call X bar Y
bar and these are villagers to the
averages the average values of x and of
Y in the solid so just to give a formula
again X bar would be one of our mass
times the double integral of x times
density D and same thing with y
why why bar is the weighted average of
the y-coordinate in your region so you
see if you take a region that symmetric
and has uniform density that will just
give you the center of the region but if
the region has a strange shape or if the
density is not homogeneous if parts of
it are heavier then you know you will
get whatever the weighted average will
be and that will be the point where this
thing would be balanced if you were
trying to balance it on the bowler on
your finger okay
okay any questions so far
nope yes I know so I know no so when you
do I mean so here I set up this I didn't
set this up as an idea right identical
yet okay so here the function that I'm
integrating is x times Delta where Delta
you know the density would be given to
me lately as a function of x and y and
then I will integrate this da and da
could mean DX dy could mean dy DX could
mean our dr d-theta i will choose how to
set it up depending maybe on the shape
of the region you know if my solid is
actually just you know going to be
around then I might want to use polar
coordinates if it's a square I might
want to use XY coordinates if it's more
complicated well I will choose depending
on how I feel about it
yes yes so Delta Delta is the density
it's in general it's a function of x and
y if you imagine that your solid you
know is not homogeneous then its density
will depend on which piece of it you're
looking at of course to compute this you
need to know the density if you have a
problem asking you to find the center of
mass of something and you have no
information about the density assume
it's uniform you know take the density
to be a constant even take it to be one
that's even easier if you want then you
know it's a general fact of math we
don't care about units so density you
know if then stays constant we might as
well take it to be one and that just
means that our mass unit becomes the
area unit yes
that's a good question no I don't think
we could actually find the center of
mass in polar coordinates by finding the
average of R or the average of theta C
for example take a disk centered at the
origin well you know that the center of
mass should be at the origin right but
the average of R is certainly not zero
because R is positive everywhere so that
doesn't work you cannot get the polar
coordinates of the center of mass just
by taking the average of our and the
average of theta by the way what we are
very afraid are you know if you take
theta to go from zero to 2pi
the average theta will be pi if you take
it to go from minus PI to PI the average
theta will dissolve so there's a problem
there so that actually just doesn't work
so we really have to compute X bar and y
bar but still we could compute them you
know we could set this up and then
switch to polar coordinates to evaluate
this integral but we'd still be
computing the average values of x and y
okay
so the next thing so we are basically
are we exploring you know mechanics and
motion of solids here so the next thing
is moment of inertia so just to remind
you in case you somehow haven't seen it
in physics yet so the moment of inertia
is basically two rotation of a solid
what the mass is - translation okay in
the following sense mass the mass of a
solid is what makes it hard to push it
you know how hard it is to throw
something is related to its mass how
hard it is to spin something on the
other hand is given by its moment of
inertia maybe I should write this down
so mass is how how'd it is to impart a
translation motion to a solid so I'm
using fancy words to it
and the moment of inertia so the
difference with the mass is that moment
of interface defined about some axis
because you choose an axis then you will
try to measure how hard it is to spin
your object around that axis for example
I can try to measure how how it is to
spin this sheet of paper about an axis
that's in the center of it so I will try
to spin it like that and see how much I
thought I have to make what portion of
paper are not very much but so that
would measure the same thing that it
would be rotation motion about that axis
so maybe some of you know the definition
if not I'm going to try to derive it
again I'm sorry but it won't be quite as
detailed as the way you've probably seen
it in physics but you know I'm not
trying to replace your physics teachers
I'm sure they're doing a great job and
so you know what's the idea for the
definition to find a formula for a
moment of inertia so the idea is to
think about kinetic energy kinetic
energy is really what you know you know
when you push something or when you try
to make it move you have to provide some
energy to it then it has kinetic energy
and if you have the right device and you
can convert back that kinetic energy
into something else so if you try to
look at the kinetic energy of a point
mass so you have something with mass m
going at velocity V well that will be
one half of the mass times the square of
the speed hopefully you've all seen that
formula sometime before now let's say
that instead of just trying to push this
mass I'm going to make it spin around
something so instead of just somewhere
maybe you know I will have the origin
and then try to actually make it go
around the origin at a certain you know
in a circle at a certain angular
velocity so for a mass M a distance R
let's call all this distance
and angular velocity let's call the
angular velocity Omega I think that's
what physicists call it so remember the
angular velocity is just the rate of
change of the angle over time okay it's
D theta DT if you want well what's the
kinetic energy now well first we have to
find out what's the speed what's the
speed well if we are going on a circle
of radius R at angular velocity Omega
that means that in unit time we rotate
by Omega and we go by a distance of r
times omega okay so the actual speed is
the radius times the angular velocity
and so the kinetic energy is one-half MV
squared which is one-half M R squared
Omega squared and so see by similarity
with that formula we can think of so
here the coefficient of V squared is the
mass and here we'll say the coefficient
of omega squared so this thing is the
moment of inertia that's how we define
the moment of inertia
okay now that's only for a point mass
and you know it's kind of fun to spin
just you know a small ball but maybe
you'd like to spin actually a larger
solid and try to define this moment of
inertia
well the moment of inertia of a solid
will be just the sum of the moments of
inertia of all the little pieces so what
we'll do is we'll just cut our solid
into little chunks and we'll sum this
thing for each little piece okay so for
a solid with density Delta so each
little piece has mass which is the
density times the amount of area this is
equal actually what and the moment of
inertia of that small portion of the
solid will be Delta M the small mass
times R squared the square of a distance
to the center to the axis around which
I'm spinning so that means if I sum
these things together well also has
moment of inertia Delta M times R
squared which is R squared times Phi
density times Delta a and so I will be
summing these things together and so the
moment of inertia about the origin will
be the double integral of R square times
density times da
okay so the final formula for the moment
of inertia about the origin is the
double integral over the region of
r-squared density da if you prefer if
you're going to do it in XY coordinates
of course our square becomes x squared
plus y squared it's the square of the
distance from the origin okay so when
you integrate this that tells you how
hard it is to spin that solid about the
origin so the motion that we try to do
we keep this fixed and then we just
rotate around the origin well so that's
a pretty bad picture but hopefully you
get what I mean okay
and then rotational energy so the name
we use for that is I 0 and then the
rotational kinetic energy is one-half
times this moment of inertia times the
square of the angular velocity so it's
in this sense that this replaces the
mass for different motions okay
what about other kinds of rotations so
in particular here we've been rotating
things about just a point in the plane
what you could imagine also is instead
you have your solid so what I've done so
far is I've secured it this way and I'm
rotating around the axis instead I could
secure it for say the horizontal axis
and then I could try to spin about the
horizontal axis so then it would you
know rotate in space in that direction
like that so let's say we do rotation
about the x axis
well the idea would still be the same ok
the moment of inertia for any small
piece of the solid would be its mass
element times the square of a distance
to the axis because that will be the
radius of the trajectory if you take
this point here it's going to go on a
circle like that centered on the x axis
so the radius will just be this distance
here well what's this distance
it's just Y or may be absolute value of
y so distance to x axis is absolute
value of y and what we actually care
about is the square of the distance so
that will just be Y squared so the
moment of inertia about the x axis is
going to be obtained by integrating Y
squared times the mass element okay it's
slightly strange that I have Y in the
inertia about the x axis but if you
think about it y tells me how far I am
from the x axis so how hard it will be
to spin around the x axis they could do
the same
any other access that they want just I
would have to sum the square of a
distance to the axis of rotation okay so
maybe I should do an example yes
oh sorry same thing as a both distance
to the x-axis because that's what we
care about right for the moment of
inertia we want the square of the
distance to the axis of rotation
okay so let's do an example let's try to
figure out if we have just a uniform
disk how hard it is to spin it around
its center so that shouldn't be very
hard to complete to figure out say that
we have a disk of radius a and we want
to rotate it about its center and let's
save it it's of uniform density and
let's take just the density to be one so
that we don't really care about the
density so what's the moment of inertia
of that well we have to integrate over
our disk R squared times the density
which is 1 times da ok what's R squared
so you have here to resist the urge to
say oh the radius is just a we know the
radius is a no it's not a because we are
looking at rotation of you know any
point inside this disk and when you are
inside the disk the distance to the
origin is not a it's less than a it's
actually anything between 0 and a ok so
just you know point out a pitfall R here
is really a function on this disk I'm
going to integrate that function don't
plug I equals a just yet ok what
coordinates do we use to compute this
integral we are probably polar
coordinates I mean unless you want a
repeat of what happened already with you
know x and y so that will tell us we
want to integrate R square times Rd Rd
theta and the bounds for R well I will
go from zero to a no matter in which
direction I go from the origin if I
fixed it our R goes from zero to R
equals a the part of this way that lives
inside the disk is always from zero to a
and theta goes from well zero
to buy for example okay
and now you can compute this integral
well I'll let you figure it out but the
inner integral becomes a to the 4 over 4
and the outer multiplies things by 2 pi
so you get PI a to the 4 over 2 no yes
ok so that's how hard it is to spin this
disk now what about instead of spinning
it about the center we decide actually
to spin it about a point on the
circumference so you know for example
think of a frisbee
you know let's begin with has this frame
and so you can actually try to make it
rotate around the point on the
circumference by holding it you know
near the raymond spinning it there how
much harder is that then around the
center well we'll try to compute now the
moment of inertia about this point so we
have two options one is we keep the
system of coordinates centered here but
then the formula for distance to this
point becomes harder the other option
which is the one I will choose is to
change the coordinates so that this
point becomes the origin ok so let's do
that
okay so about a point on the seven funds
what I would have to do maybe is set up
my region like that you know now I have
moved the origin so that it's on the
circumference of the disk and they will
again try to find the moment of inertia
of this disk about the origin so it's
still the double integral of R squared
da but now I want to find out how to set
up the integral so I could try to use X
Y coordinates and it would work
oh I can use polar coordinates and
actually it works a little bit better
that way
but both both are doable so let's say I
do it this way so I have to figure out
how to set up my bounds right so what
are the bounds for R well if I fix a
value of theta so it means I chose an
angle here and now I'm shooting away
from the origin in that direction so I
enter my region at i-40 that hasn't
changed
question is where do I exit the region
so what is that distance
so maybe you've seen it in recitation
maybe not so let's see well actually I
should have written down the radius of
the circle is a so this distance here is
2a okay so if you draw this segment in
here you know that here you have a right
angle so you have a right triangle the
hypotenuse here has length 2 a this
angle is Theta where this length is 2a
cosine theta so the polar coordinates
equation of this circle passing through
the origin is R equals 2a cosine theta
so I will go from 0 to 2 a cosine theta
okay that's the distance now what are
the bounds for theta it's not quite 0 to
2 pi because actually you see in this
direction if I shoot away in this
direction I will never meet my region so
I have to actually think of it now
well the directions in which I will
actually hit my circle are all the
directions in the right half of the
plane I mean of course I should very
close to the axis you might think oh I
won't be in there but actually that's
not true because here the circle is
tangent to the axis so no matter which
direction I take I will still have a
little tiny piece so the angle actually
goes from minus PI over 2 to PI over 2
so now if you compute that you will get
well the inner integral will be R to the
4 over 4 between 0 and 2 a cosine theta
which will turn out to be 4 8 over 4
cosine to the for theta and now you will
integrate
that on minus PI over 2 to PI over 2 and
well that's again the evil integral that
we had yesterday
so either we remember have method from
yesterday or we remember from yesterday
that actually does formulas in the notes
to help you so on a homework you can use
these formulas in the notes at the
beginning of section 3b there's formulas
for these particular kinds of integrals
and that will end up being three halves
of Pi a to the 4 so in case you wanted
to know it's three times harder to spin
a frisbee about a point on the
circumference than around the center see
we got three times the moment of inertia
about the center ok that's it have a
nice weekend